대학생활 하면서요 우리를 아주 힘들게 하는 두 가지
그거 시험하고 리포트잖아요
그 중에 하나인 리포트 이거 오늘 해결하고 가보자
리포트는요 이것저것 짝이 깨는 게 아니에요
자기의 생각 자기의 이야기를 써내려가는 것이 리포트
오늘 말씀드리는 세 가지 절차만 잘 지키셔서요
자기 생각 자기 이야기를 쓰시면 무조건 A플러스 받게 되실 겁니다
궁금하시면 이 영상을 끝까지 시청해 보시기 바랍니다
안녕하세요 무엇이든 세 가지로 가르쳐드리는 명지대 교수 김익환입니다
리포트 쓰는 거요 이거 대학 졸업할 때까지
아니 석사 박사 과정 다니시는 분들도요
모두가 반드시 풀고 가야 될 숙제잖아요
매 학기마다 다가오는 리포트 지옥 거기서부터 우리 탈출해 보자고요
사실 이거 리포트 쓰는 거요 대학에서 좀 가르쳐야 되는데요
아무도 안 가르쳐요 그래서 제가 오늘 영상을 찍는 거죠
그러니까 여러분들 꼭 좀 길더라도 끝까지 들어주시기 바랍니다
리포트는 베끼는 거다 이 생각만 버리시면
리포트 잘 쓰는 요령 생각보다 쉽게 터득하실 수 있어요
오늘 저하고 같이 알아보시기 바랍니다
다시 말하지만요 리포트 베끼거나 짝이 깨하면 A플러스 절대 안 나옵니다
먼저 결론부터 말씀드리면요
나는 리포트 주제 내용 중에 이러이러한 점이 궁금했다
그래서 이런 걸 찾아보고
물어보기도 했다 그랬더니 이런 걸 알게 되었다 라고 쓰는 거예요
내가 궁금한 거 이거 문제의식이라고요
궁금증을 풀어가는 과정 이거 방법론이기도 하고요
연구설계이기도 해요
알아낸 거요 이게 연구결과죠
좀 어려운 용어지만 문제의식 연구방법과 연구설계
연구 결과를 써 내려가면 무조건 A플러스 맞습니다
이렇게 전문용어로 말하니까 좀 어렵죠
예를 들어서 제가
쉽게 이제 이야기해 볼게요
교수님이요 한국 현대사의 특징에 대해서 리포트를 써내라고 했어요
그럼 한국 현대사의 특징이 뭐지 이거 엄청 궁금해요
아니에요 이거 범위가 너무 넓고요
추상적이라서 전혀 궁금하지 않아요
그냥 막막하긴 하죠
내가 궁금해 할 만한 구체적인 거를 무조건 아무거나 떠올리셔야 돼요
근데 아무것도 떠오르지 않잖아요
그래서 위키피디아 이런 거 있죠
이런 거요 이런 거를 호로록 보면서 구체적인 궁금증을 떠올리시는 것부터 출발해야 됩니다
한국사 연표를 보니까요 궁금한 게 몇 가지 떠올랐어요
예를 들자면 경부고속도로 한일협정 60항쟁 뭐 이런 게 떠올랐다고 하자고요
그럼 그 중에 하나를 선택할 거예요
그냥 제일 궁금한 걸 직관적으로 선택하는 걸 저는 권합니다
너무 2단계에서 신중하잖아요
초기 단계에서 이미 지치고 재미없어져요
경부고속도로가 제일 궁금하고 뭔가 끌리고 또 비교적 궁금한 것들을 선택하는 거예요
또 비교적 뭔가 찾는 게 쉬울 것 같다는 생각에 이르렀어요
그럼 경부고속도로를 통해서 한국 현대사의 특징을 찾아봐야지
이렇게 생각하는 것이 문제의식이 되는 거예요
대체로 제목도 여기서 바로 나와요
어때요 생각보다 쉽죠
경부고속도로를 통해 본 한국 현대사의 특징
이런 제목은 일단 교수님이 선호하는 제목입니다
다른 예를 하나 더 들어볼게요
노령화 시대의 정책에 대해서 리포트를 써오라고 했다고 가정을 해 볼게요
그럼요
할머니나 주변 사람들을 떠올려 보세요
그러니까 구체적인 궁금증을 자기 실생활 또는 연표나 사전 이런 데서 찾아내는 작업을 먼저 하시라는 거예요
그랬더니요 우리 할머니는 엄마가 사이가 너무 안 좋아
노인과 가족관계라는 문제이시죠
우리 할머니는 너무너무 심심해서
이거는요 노인의 심심함 우울증 뭐 이런 게 떠오르잖아요
우리 할머니는 돈이 없어서 너무 고생하셔
이거 노인의 경제적 공피배 문제잖아요
자 이렇게 생각한 다음에요
한 개 혹은 두 개 정도로 궁금증을 좁혀보는 거예요
심심함 우울증을 택했다고 하면요
노인 세대의 무료와 우울증에 대한 정책대안 연구
뭐 이런 문제의식이 떠오르게 되는 거죠
이 제목도 왠지 A플러스 예감이 들죠
이 두 가지 예에서 제가 가르쳐드리고 싶은 거는요
구체적인 이 구체적인 게 중요합니다
이 구체적인 궁금증으로 리포트 주제를 처리하시라는 거예요
현대사의 특징인데 경부고속도로
노령화 시대인데 노인 우울증으로
구체적인 문제의식을 설정하고
리포트를 준비하시는 것이 첫 번째 요령입니다
이것만 찾아내셔도요
일단 A플러스에 한 걸음 다가가시게 될 겁니다
자 이제 두 번째 단계
이 궁금증을 어떻게 알 수 있을지에 대한 정책대안 연구를 하시면 됩니다.
자 이제 두 번째 단계 이 궁금증을 어떻게 알 수 있을지에 대한 정책대안 연구를 하시면 됩니다.
이 궁금증을 어떻게 풀어 가느냐
제가 다른 영상에서 말씀드린 적이 있는데요
모르는 걸 알아가는 방법은 세 가지 밖에 없다 그랬죠
사전 논문 등을 찾아봐서 안다
읽고 아는 거죠
잘 아는 사람에게 물어봐서 안다
곰곰이 스스로 생각해서 안다
이 세 가지 잖아요
자 우선 찾아봐야 됩니다
사전, 기사, 논문 이렇게 세 가지를 선택하세요
사전은 백과사전 아무거나 좋아요
사이트에 들어가면 다 있습니다
기사는
신문기사 아카이브가 각 신문사마다 다 들어가 있어요
이것도 사이트를 통해서 여러분들이 검색해서 찾을 수 있어요
논문은 DBPI에서 검색해서 찾으라고
제가 다른 영상에서 이미 가르쳐드렸죠
자 이렇게 찾을 때 중요한 것은 선구안
자신의 선구안을 믿으세요
사전을 하나, 기사는 두 개, 논문은 세 편을 찾으세요
이거 모범생들은요
며칠을 고생하면서 고르고 또 고르고 이렇게 합니다
그렇게 하지 마세요
그냥 직관적으로 어? 이거 괜찮은데? 하고 제목만 봅시다.
제목만 보고 고르세요
무엇을 고르냐보다도요
읽고 모르는 것을 알아가는 것이 훨씬 더 중요하기 때문에
고르는 데 시간을 쓰지 마세요
뭐든 찾은 거에는요
내가 모르는 내용이 당연히 들어있겠죠
우리가 뭘 찾는 것은
현재 모르는 것을 좀 더 알기 위해서잖아요
그러니까 좀 시원치 않은 게 걸려도요
아무 문제 없어요
안 찾고 안 보는 것보다 100배 낫죠
먼저 사전을 보면서 메모
몇 년에
경부고속도로가 만들어지기 시작해서 언제 공사가 끝났고
누가 왜 만들었고
그리고 그 결과가 한국사에 어떤 영향을 미쳤는지
그리고 중요한 사건이나 에피소드로는 뭐가 있는지
이거 노트에 메모해 둬야 해요
이 정도는 백과사전에 다 나옵니다
그리고 외우세요
배내어 보세요
아 경부고속도로는 언제 만들어졌구나
박정희가 독일 가서 아투반 보고
급속한 경제성장을 위해서 만들었구나
아하 만드는 과정에서 토지 수용이 이루어졌구나
그때 정치작업 같은 게 막 만들어지기도 했구나
현대건설하고 유착도 이루어졌네
뭐 이런 걸요
백과사전 차원에서 다 발견할 수 있을 겁니다
아하 아하 하시면서요
노트를 하게 되는 거죠
이거 사실요
리포트를 쓰기 위해서가 아니라요
우리가 모르는 거를 알아가는 과정이라고 생각하면 꽤 재밌답니다
자 기사를 이제 찾으세요
아투반으로 하나 찾고
토지 수용에 대해서 하나 찾았어요
그 다음에 논문을 찾아요
국토개발 쪽에서요?
국토개발 쪽에서 하나 찾고
정치작업에 관해서 하나 찾았어요
자 기사는 금방 읽으니까 냅두고요
논문을 보는데
요령은 서론하고 결론만 먼저 읽는 거예요
앞에 기본 지식을 백과사전을 통해서 이미 알았기 때문에요
읽기가 훨씬 수월해질 거예요
읽을 때는요 꼭 형광펜
이 형광펜을 쓰는 게 중요해요
핵심 키워드에 표시를 해가면서 읽어야 해요
그리고요 본문을 보는데 특히 표 나오죠
지도 같은 거 나오잖아요
개념도 이런 거 나오죠
이런 거 중시하셔야 됩니다
이렇게 해둔 다음에
모른 걸 아는 두 번째는 뭐죠?
묻는 거죠 묻는 거
선배나 교수님한테 물어보는 거예요
경부고속도로 건설의 특징이 어떤 게 있어요?
왜 박정희는 그 경부고속도로
그렇게 급하게 건설했는데요?
하고 물어보는 거예요
다른 영상에서 제가 말했듯이요
이거는 특히 교수님들은 답해주는 걸 되게 좋아하시는 거예요
찾아봐서 아는 과정하고요
물어봐서 듣고 아는 과정하고요
그 과정을 거치잖아요
아마 여러분들은 경부고속도로에 대해서
꽤 이해의 폭이 넓어진 자신을 발견하게 될 겁니다
아마요 박정희 전 대통령의 독일 방문과 아우터관에 대한 애착
정부 주도의 인프라 개발
정치작용과 부정
재벌과의 유착
포항제철 등의 남부 지역과
서울의 물류 기반을 확보해서
경제성장에 드라이브를 거는 거
이런 것 등등의 키워드를 여러분들이 발견하게 되겠죠
물론 개발독재라는 개념어도 아마 알겠죠?
그 다음에 뭐라고요?
곰곰이 생각해보면
경부고속도로의 건설과정의 특징이 뭐지?
이거 세 가지로 생각하는 습관 한번 들어보시기 바랍니다
특징 세 가지가 뭘까 하고 생각을 해 보는 거죠
아하 결국 물류기반을 확보해서
급속한 경제성장을 시키는 거 이거 하나고
그것을 정부가 주도했고
그 과정에서 정치자금을 불법적으로 확보하는 그런
비민주적인 성격이 있었다는 게 다른 하나이고
재벌 주도의 경제가 정착되게 된
하나의 계기가 됐구나
요게 세 번째구나 하는 생각이
여러분들 머릿속에 정리될 수 있을지도 모릅니다
이거 좀 어려운 얘기지만요
제가 하라는 대로 하시면
제가 지금 말하는 것 같은
결론에 도달할 가능성이 높아져요
궁금증이 풀렸으니 이제 사실 다 온 거예요
자 이제 세 번째
문제의식 앞에 얘기했죠?
문제의식
연구의 과정에서
과정과 방법 그리고 연구 결과를 쓰는 거예요
노트북을 켜세요
그리고 제목을 적고
이미 정해뒀으니까 제목 적는 건 되게 쉽잖아요
그 다음에 할 일은요
목차를 적는 거예요
생각을 자꾸 하면서 고치고 고치고 해야 돼요
앞서서요
아는 거 세 가지 중에
스스로 생각해서 아는 거 나왔었잖아요
그때 이미 생각이 많이 정리가 돼 있을 거예요
이 정리된 머리
자기 스스로의 머리를 믿고요
노트북을 켜고 치세요
제가 자료 화면에 예시의 목차를 드릴게요
1. 서론
1.1. 문제의식
1.2. 연구의 과정과 방법
됐죠?
처음에 우리 얘기한 거 두 가지가 목차에 들어갔잖아요
그 다음에 2. 경부고속도로의 건설과정과 그 결과
2.1. 건설의 계기와 과정
2.2. 건설과정의 특징
2.3. 경부고속도로의 경제적 영향
3. 건설의 계기와 과정 2.2. 건설과정의 특징 2.3. 경부고속도로의 경제적 영향
한국현대사의 특징이잖아요
왜냐하면 경부고속도로의 특징을 가지고
한국현대사의 특징을 살피기로 했으니까
3.1. 군사정권과 부정축제
3.2. 개발독재
3.3. 재벌주도성
4. 결론 끝
어때요?
뭐 여러 가지 선택지가 있겠죠
하지만 제가 예시한 거와 같은 이런 목차를
여러분들이 알물 달성하게 되면 쓸 수 있게 될 겁니다
꽤 매력적이지 않아요?
선생님
저 생각보다 선생님이 한 것처럼 그렇게 잘할 수 있을 것 같지는 않아요
아니에요
스스로 믿으세요
노트북을 켜놓고 목차를 계속 바꿔가면서 시도를 해보시기 바랍니다
내용은 나중에 넣으시고요
일단 마음에 드는 목차
자기 머릿속에 있는 내용을 중심으로 해서
목차를 만들어 보는 게 우선입니다
그 다음에 그동안 본 사전, 기사, 논문 내용들 있잖아요
이거 노트해놓으라고 했어요
메모해놓으라고 했습니다
얘를 목차의 1에서 4에
사이에다가 적절한 위치를 잡고 쳐넣으세요
쳐넣으세요
이게 중요해요
일단은 자기가 갖고 있는 재료를 다 쳐넣은 상태에서
다시 읽으면서 쳐넣은 내용의 순서를 좀 바꾸기도 하고요
자기의 생각을 키워드 위주로 조금씩 써넣기도 하는 거예요
이런 것을 반복적으로 거친 다음에 이야기 흐름을 잡으시면 됩니다
그렇게 해둔 상태에서요
제일 앞에서부터 글을 써내려가기 시작합니다
키워드, 표
개념도, 그림, 사진
이런 게 이미 노트북에 왕창 들어가 있잖아요
그렇기 때문에 자기 이야기를 만들어가면서
글을 써내려가는 것이 훨씬 수월하게 느껴지실 겁니다
자 이렇게 하는데 시간이 얼마나 드는가 한번 생각해 볼까요
문제의식 생각하고요
제목 잡고 하는데 많이 들어야 2시간이에요
물론 절대 시간을 말하는 겁니다
머릿속에 같은 생각을 넣어두고 며칠간 해도 무방해요
잠깐 잠깐 생각해도 무방하다는 얘기죠
하지만 짬짬이 하면요
실제 들어가는 시간은 절대로 2시간 지나지 않습니다
선택하고 찾아서 읽고 노트에 키워드 넣어두고 하는데
최소한 10시간 정도는 소요돼요
이거 시간 꽤 걸려요
교수님한테 물어보는 것도 포함해서요
이렇게 해둔 상태에서 글을 쓰는데 적어도 4, 5시간이 걸려요
이것도 절대 시간입니다
A플러스 리포트 하나 쓰는데 15시간, 16시간 정도 드는 거잖아요
너무 많이 걸려요? 아니에요
이 정도는 여러분들 투자하시면 됩니다
투자하시는 것을 저는 적극적으로 권해요
왜냐하면 성적도 잘 받으실 수 있지만요
실력이 부쩍부쩍 커갑니다
자 여기서 생각하셔야 할 점은요
시간 배분이에요
4과목을 한 학기에 리포트를 써야 된다고 하면
한 학기가 보통 4개월이잖아요
개강하고 한 달 정도 지난 후부터 미리미리 하나씩 해 가야 돼요
선생님 아니 강의 시작한 지 한 달 지난 다음에 놀아야지
언제 리포트를 그때부터 시작합니까?
이렇게 얘기하시죠 물론 그래요
근데요 정말 해가지고 좀 이렇게 몸에 익숙해지잖아요
한 학기 내내 엄청 편하네요
학기 말에 그 지옥으로부터 여러분들 벗어날 수 있어요
리포트 지옥 말입니다
물론 하루에 1시간 정도를 투자해서 하는 것을 제가 전제로 얘기 드리는 거예요
그래야 15시간이 되잖아요
하루에 1시간씩 2주하면 15시간이잖아요
수강을 하잖아요
근데 리포트 준비를 위해서 하루에 1시간 공부한다?
이건 하셔야 돼요
궁금증을 풀어가고 자기가 안 것에 대해서 글을 쓰는 걸 무려 4개나 하는 거예요
하루에 1시간이면 정말 짧은 시간이에요
이건 일종의 습관
하루에 1시간은 4개의 리포트를 쓰는데 투자하겠다고 결심
습관과 결심의 문제예요
결심해서 이 습관을 들이라는 얘기죠
사실 더 중요한 거는요
이 방법을 습득하시게 되면요
모르는 것을 알아가고
그것을 적절하게 글이나 보고서의 형태로 쓸 수 있는
그런 능력이 쑥쑥 커간다는 거예요
이 능력은요
공부를 할 때만 쓰는 게 아니에요
일을 할 때도 아주 중요한 능력입니다
회사에 들어갔어요
자기에게 프로젝트가 주어졌어요
똑같은 방법으로 처리하시는 거예요
이걸 할 수 있다는 자신감을 갖는 것만으로도요
여러분들은 그 어떤 어려운 과제가 닥치더라도
두려움 없이 착착 그것도 시간을 잘 배분해서
별로 시간 많이 들이지 않고 처리할 수 있는 그런 사람이 되는 거예요
되게 복잡했죠?
한번 정리해볼게요
에이플 리포트스 넘버 1
구체적인 문제의식을 정한다
한국 현대사의 특징 같으면
경부고속도로라는 구체적인 문제의식을 설정하는 거죠
2. 사전, 기사, 논문 등을 찾아서 읽고
선배나 교수들에게 묻고
계속 생각을 정리해보고 하면서 모르는 것을 알아간다
알아간 것을 노트하기도 하고
논문 등에 표시해두기도 한다
3. 세 가지 정도로
알아간 것을 나눠보고
목차를 짜고
표시해둔 것을 쳐놓고
순서를 조금씩 바꾸거나
내 생각을 메모하듯이 쳐넣는다
조금씩 글을 써내려가서 완성한다
이겁니다
여러분들 새학기입니다
새내기 여러분들 그리고 대학생 혹은 대학원생 여러분들
에이플러스 리포트 쓰기
이거 꼭 한번 시도해보시기 바랍니다
쉽지는 않아요
한번 해보시고 나면요
그 다음부터는 생각보다 수월하게 같은 작업을 해가실 수 있어요
감사합니다
대학생활 하면서 리포트 걱정 없어지는 거죠
게다가 지식과 능력이 자신에게 차곡차곡 쌓여가는 것을 느끼시게 될 겁니다
잘 안되시거나 모르시거나 하는 것이 있으면
댓글 달아주시고요 저한테 물어주세요
다른 방법도 아시는 분들도 있을 수 있어요
댓글로 지혜 나눔 부탁드리겠습니다
여러분들 사랑합니다
구독 좋아요 알람 설정까지 부탁드립니다